là je sais que je peux progresser face à
moi puisqu'on a un vent de face qui
emmène donc éventuellement nos odeurs
derrière nous donc en fait quand je vais
province et si je fais pas de bruit les
animaux peuvent pas anticiper sur mon
arrivée parce qu'ils n'ont pas d'odeur
je pars comme ça je pars pas n'importe
comment
je sais que effectivement les animaux
aussi doivent sortir chevreuils cerfs
vont sortir de la partie gauche de la
forêt donc là où nous nous trouvons donc
je longe l'orée de la forêt à gauche
pour que s'ils sortent je me retrouve
dans leurs angles morts de vue
maintenant c'est parti
silence
les animaux peuvent surgir de n'importe
où c'est une question si vous voulez de
l'exercice aussi de l'oeil ses yeux être
capable en quelques secondes de capter
le moindre petit détail qui n'est pas
normale entre guillemets de bois qui
s'entassent au goût de fougères si on
n'a pas l'habitude d'observer la nature
en fait cet état qui devaient échapper
vous connaissez les habitudes les lieux
fréquentés par les magouilles
photographié plus vous pouvez anticiper
sur son activité et dont le but étant de
prendre la photo la plus délicate la
plus rare autant que possible donc là il
s'agit d'une femelle busard saint-martin
qui est venu se poser pour prendre son
bain après une matinée de chasse un
rapace qui se baigne c'est vraiment peu
fréquent et quand on si on travaille à
distance qui va se passer comme problème
on va avoir tout les roseaux les
végétaux qui vont empêcher la vue de
l'animal
donc là je suis à peu près à trois
mètres cinquante du sujet
pas évidente
enfin ce que je suis en train de faire
un petit peu je sais limiter un petit
peu la plus variable
la buse variable d'un rapace qui occupe
en couple permanent aux sédentaires qui
occupe un territoire forestier et si
vous voulez comme tout rapaces comme
tout prédateur ils ont un territoire de
chasse
donc dès qu'ils entendent éventuellement
un congénère ils viennent aux devants
pour éventuellement le chasser
on peut être plusieurs heures sans y
avoir du tout et c'est ce qui fait
l'intérêt aussi de ce travail c'est la
surprise
je
là il s'agit de fonds peu macroule c'est
un combat de territoire c'est des
oiseaux qui sont extrêmement
territoriaux à la période ddm - nous
nous trouvons actuellement d'environ une
colonie de fourmis rousses des bois la
fourmi cap jusqu'à qui en fait est très
révélateur d'un écosystème en parfaite
santé puisque cette espèce là elle est
remarquable est intéressante parce que
elle permet de limiter la propagation
par exemple entre autres des punaises
qui sont déçus ceux de sève et donc ils
risqueraient d'affaiblir les arbres et l
pré date parce que c'est des prédateurs
elle près d'ath beaucoup beaucoup de ces
finales
tout mon travail de photographe
naturaliste c'est de dévoiler une
richesse faunistique notamment qu'entre
les cours d'eau les étangs la forêt les
prairies les jachères et même les
cultures c'est d'une richesse qui n'a
rien à envier à d'autres régions